au 16ème siècle boîtier n'était encore
qu'une toute petite ville de province
depuis elle a grandi elle est devenue
capitale du poitou charentes
monsieur pierre vertadier pouvez vous
nous présenter le nouveau visage de
poitiers le nouveau visage de potiers je
peux vous le décrire dans l'avenir mais
il est en train de se construire de se
faire la population poitiers aux mains
de 3% par an et ce niveau devrait
s'accélérer nous aurons je pense 80000
habitants prochain recensement très
rapidement avant la fin du siècle 150
c'est donc une ville à une autre
dimension que nous sommes en train de
prévoir le problème le plus crucial qui
découlent de nos situation topographique
c'est celui des mois de communication
nous avons un noeud routier très
important à l'endroit décrit horde de
pain nous l'avons cru indispensable de
mettre en priorité la réalisation de la
déviation de potiers de la future
autoroute a10 les nouveaux quartiers se
construisent vous avez pu observer que
les premiers logements d'azur ont été
livrés depuis deux mois de septembre et
doivent continuer à se
développer pense construire pendant une
encore quatre ans pour amener une
agglomération nouvelle de 20 minutes du
temps presque une petite ville à elle
toute seule
les liaisons entre ces deux villes celle
qui a déjà été construite un peu plus au
sud à saint cyprien les sables et qui
compte près de 15000 habitants nous ont
posé des problèmes redoutable
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
accéléré la réalisation d'une voie de
rocade est à poitiers qui est maintenant
presque terminé qui sera certainement
fini dans le premier semestre 1968 voie
d'une largeur de 40 mètres et d'une
longueur de 4 km environ et la nécessité
9 millions d'investissements de la part
de la ville de poitiers avec une
subvention d'état de 30%
l'extension de cette voie est d'ailleurs
prévu il franchira klein et ira
rejoindre la route de bordeaux à la
sortie sud de poitiers
parallèlement à cette voie de rocade
nous avons dû penser à la pénétration la
pénétration de poitiers qui est mal aisé
car la traversée d'une 1re en amène des
goulots d'étranglement et ralentit
considérablement la circulation aux
heures de pointe nous a imposé de
d'envisager la création d'une voie de
pénétration qui avoue tirer baisse du
marché qui franchirait le plein sur un
viaduc
il s'agit là d'un ouvrage très
importants dont les blancs sont
maintenant définitivement établie qui
devrait commencer au cours du cinquième
plan pour se terminer au début du vième
savait que notre campus universitaire se
développe très rapidement la faculté des
sciences est maintenant presque terminé
tout l'ensemble universitaire de
poitiers sera situé sur ce plateau est
le long des routes de chauvigny
et de limoges près de la route de
l'image également doit se situer le
futur centre hospitalo universitaires
pour lequel un pavillon de 855 me tour
avec un héliport au sommet est prévu
donc investissements importants pour
l'extérieur du côté actuelle mais à
l'intérieur même de l'ancienne ville
vous avez prévu également d'importants
travaux la circulation à poitiers est
malaisé nous allons ouvrir à voir la fin
de l'année une rue qui desservira les
quartiers du centre haut de la rue
gambetta la poste nous projetons
également nous brillons dans une gaze et
que nous allons récupérer bientôt et
prolongement de la rue magenta verbe le
sac vers le pablos est nous faisons
provisoirement une gare routière en
surface avant d'enterrer et il était
indispensable de dégager le centre de
poitiers de l'encombrement posées par
les autobus interurbains la ville de
poitiers n'a pas que des projets à long
terme
elle s'occupe dès maintenant de réaliser
et dans tous les domaines
nous nous préoccupons de dégager
l'amérique est devenu trop petit de la
caserne des pompiers qui est maintenant
presque terminé et qui a représenté
quand même
3500 bekim de béton armé quatre mille
mètres cubes de terrassement et un
investissement de 5 millions 600 mille
francs
l'abattoir car poitiers quand même ou
100 d'une région agricole où les nuages
est prioritaire l'abattoir est agrandi
nous allons établir une chaîne de froid
et nous avons été subventionné par
bruxelles
il s'agit encore de 3 millions
d'investissements nous envisageons
également de favoriser la construction
par l'initiative rêver d'un îlot de
logements et 2
boutique extrêmement importants qui vont
être situé près de l'hôtel de ville le
long de la rue jean jaurès et qui nous
permettra de faire une liaison
extrêmement rapide entre la rue jean
jaurès axe de pénétration depuis limoges
et saumur jusqu'à la poste par
l'intermédiaire de la rue étonné de la
rue jean jaurès prolonger mais alors
monsieur le maire pour tous ces travaux
du centre de la vieille ville
quels sont les investissements prévus eh
bien nous pensons qu'il faudrait compter
pour à peu près un milliard pour arriver
à faire tous les investissements prévus
au point de vue assainissement voirie
les problèmes d'urbanisation proprement
sans compter les nids ce que nous
voulions fait au point de vue culturel
et social car nous avons deux noms de
rue jean jaurès en pré billon et nous
sont financés je pense et 1968 par une
subvention importante du ministère des
affaires sociales un foyer d'une
travailleuse et un peu plus bas dans le
quartier artistique le plus ancien
routier au près de la cathédrale et du
temple saint-jean à projets de
musée moderne sur l'ancien emplacement
de l'abbaye de sainte croix de guy doré
nous coûter à peu près 600 600 millions
d'anciens francs soit 6 millions
nouveaux francs ainsi vous voyez que
dans tous les domaines la vocation
universelle de potiers s'affirme aussi
bien dans le logement qu dans la
circulation que dans le développement de
ce qui est son patrimoine c'est-à-dire
le développement culturel et universités